it is coming closer and closer to our
borders there is a real risk for a new
armed conflict in europe
i put you the words of the ukraine
ambassador this morning on sky news who
said that many dead russian bodies will
be returned to moscow if putin moves
against his country
tensions between russia and the west are
the worst they've been since the cold
war at the end of last year vladimir
putin demanded sweeping guarantees that
ukraine would be kept out of nato and it
would roll back activities in eastern
european countries that have already
joined the demands were seen as
completely unreasonable in the west but
putin's threatened military action if
they're not met of course we are moving
troops troops are exercising and it is
no secret that they are preparing to
deter any kind of threat with relations
on a knife edge meetings have been
hastily called to seek compromise
[Music]
ukraine has been in a conflict with
russia since 2014 when russia illegally
annexed crimea
but in the last few months more than a
hundred thousand russian troops have
amassed near the ukrainian border
nato's ruled out sending any of its
allied forces to support the former
soviet country should russia invade but
says it would bolster forces in alliance
countries in the region if that happened
any use of force against ukraine
would be a severe
and serious strategic mistake by russia
and it will have severe
consequences now the kremlin wants
bulletproof guarantees that ukraine
won't become a nato member we need
ironclad waterproof bulletproof
legally binding
guarantees
never ever becoming member of nato
that the alliance ends its security
cooperation with ukraine
the u.s and nato have called these
demands non-starters
we will not slam the door shut
on nato's open door policy nato wants to
avoid a russian invasion of ukraine at
all costs with some sort of compromise
but it can't be seen to be caving in to
military pressure
the west is prepared to talk about
changes to military exercises in the
region and the location of missiles
of course this is about more than just
ukraine russia and the west have
different ways of seeing the world
you could have perhaps treated russia as
a potential ally and strengthened trust
but no instead you tried to keep
breaking us up
russia sees nato as an aggressor pushing
into its former territories having
promised it
wouldn't i've said this many times and
you probably know this well not a single
inch to the east nato guaranteed us that
in the 1990s and you know what they
cheated us five waves of nato expansion
and there you go they're now in romania
and poland with weapon systems
for nato this is about the principle of
sovereignty a sovereign country should
be able to join any organization of its
choice for russia it's more
psychological a country that's been
repeatedly invaded from the west is
deeply suspicious of nato expanding
towards its borders
in the last few years russia has
allegedly tried to influence elections
russians massively intervened in our
elections its military are involved in
ukraine crimea syria and now kazakhstan
and its malign influence online
manipulating social media for example is
felt all over the world
with all that in mind it may seem
unlikely that any deal let alone
friendship could be struck between
western countries and russia
russia says it doesn't intend to invade
ukraine but if vladimir putin's demands
aren't met there will be consequences
for security across the whole of europe
time is running out to defuse that
threat